what exactly is one of the things that
publicly you think that people got wrong
you're saying that there's all these
people well you know me for a long time
and you've known a little bit about some
of the of the drama and different
relationships one of the most important
things I never really publicly addressed
in a major way was the relationship with
Tyga and the Kardashians situation and
how all that got spend and turned around
and there was a lot of mistruths that
became a huge story because outrageous
yeah you get involved so that for those
that don't like the public story yes was
and this is very brief that you were
that Tyga was cheating on kylie jenner
right with you yes and he was anyway and
and then they whatever and then it
became a social media thing but that
really wasn't the whole subject of the
situation someone was impersonating me
on Instagram they made like 20 different
Instagram accounts and they were
threatening to release some sex tape
which doesn't exist to my knowledge
because we never shot a sex tape
at least not aware of such a thing and
someone was threatening to like extort
you know release the sex tape they
didn't give this money
it was psycho it was insane the world
was like coming at me so hard and I
never addressed it because I didn't want
to like make any wrong decision say the
wrong things I really just wanted to
protect him in every way that I are you
owe me or did you out him no okay
because I'm saying people this as for as
far as his lawyers were concerned and
what they told me when they were working
with my lawyers and by the way I was
under strict settlement negotiation
agreement or a negotiation situation the
entire time settlement for they were
trying to buy me in confidentiality and
I wouldn't agree to anything I didn't
want any money from him I just wanted
him to tell the truth so I could move
forward with my life let me ask you when
you say you wanted him to tell the truth
you wanted him to admit that you guys
were didn't even have to admit that I
did in the written statement and
everything that he could have just did a
joint statement saying that we were just
friends people just made up this
salacious story and you know standing up
for you know trans rights simply saying
you shouldn't discriminate against my
friend because we're friends Baba blah I
made it easy for him but apparently had
already lines that he didn't know
to whoever he was dealing with but his
attorneys and my attorneys know the
truth but you didn't out him no I didn't
as far as the attorneys said to me that
his phone was hacked and the messages
they told the public the messages for
not real his penis pictures were real
because those were released but that his
phone was hacked and they were trying to
figure out who the hacker was so I never
outed anyone wait his phone was hacked I
don't know what you mean they said that
the messages weren't real that's one
took someone took either he was hacked
and someone took the nude pictures of
him and released them or that someone
that he was saying that wasn't me
released that but one of the fake
accounts or whatever no not to think it
counts when it's someone else that he
had dealt with before me like at all I
just normal genetic girl I see that he
had sent in confidence these pictures
had released them or something of the
sort why is there so much embarrassment
about it from these guys well the world
did humiliate him the world words I was
attacking him so I didn't understand at
the time and I was trying my best to be
as cool as possible about it and and be
really protective but they didn't
humiliate him like why don't you say
like yeah this is who I am and this if
you get caught I get getting caught
cheating stinks no one I've got caught
it's embarrassing but it's I got caught
too though you were in a race in a
relationship so it was interesting for
me and my person was high-profile more
so than him so that's another reason why
I stayed quiet right whereas you are
sitting there going like this becomes a
story it becomes a public thing and when
it becomes a public thing not by your
doing yeah you start getting lied about
so you've got no other option than to
come forward and say no no all right
fine here's the story I wasn't gonna say
here's the story even a year later every
time I turn around there's like Google
Alerts and there's all kinds of people
putting up articles like even a year
later when I'm not doing anything right
no press for it not discussing it
whatsoever it's constantly I'm
constantly being tagged and dragged and
stuff so it's like it's like okay but it
has raised your profile on some level
you have to like it because it's like
it's not it's not that I'm saying you're
a virgin benefit me at all when you
become an shalay destroyed me personal
relationships the person that was
actually in love with I had to walk away
from one because I don't want that
happened to him I didn't want him to be
publicly shamed like that I didn't want
him to experience what that felt like
for the other person but why
public shaming if the person is open
about meaning if you're dating some and
you're dating that person and all of a
sudden hey you both like each other and
you're dating where's the shame in it I
get it
when you have a major contract when you
have endorsements when you have other
things going on in life I am
understanding to the idea that society
has not completely accepted us you got
an understanding to those things you
know what I mean I definitely took those
things into consideration and it wasn't
that we were particularly cheating we
had been seeing each other for a few
years but I believe during the time that
he had started dating this girl and he
didn't tell me anything about her I'm
Jeremy Tiger II yeah yeah we had at
least bent a couple of times together
during the time depending on when they
started dating right I was seeing him
since 2013 mm-hmm until right before all
this stuff happened yeah and then I
found out so how'd you meet how we meet
he contacted me through one of his
friends when I went to one of the
concerts and asked to see me it's
amazing how often that happens and
that's the way it happens and then like
just a different message I just took
like Wow must be cool to be a rapper you
start rhyming words in your head going
maybe I can make a career out of this
yeah I was angry at him you know what I
mean Mikey I wasn't angry at him I
didn't feel like he was a bad guy I
still don't
mm-hm people just mishandled the
situation a lot of people didn't know
the truth whoever were doing their job
for him obviously didn't know any of the
true details of the situation so they
just thought someone's bucking with him
let's take her down yeah so and I tried
to understand that but then at the same
time I have your lawyer and my lawyer
discussing things every single day for a
month or more and you're telling me to
be quiet
who mentioned it first I mentioned what
the whole thing the whole situation I
have no idea it was released to the text
messages and pictures were released to
someone and it ended up in somebody's
blogs and articles in it just for the
qualifier I woke up to my Instagram
literally blowing up that's how I found
out so oh so you didn't write the text
messages no it's theirs
I have I have asked them to say that
publicly numerous times they knew that I
did not release anything theirs
there's no proof and no such thing
because it didn't happen from me they
were saying that his phone was hacked or
someone else released the stuff so how
the hell did I release anything but
amazing truth and statement that his
attorney said it was sent from someone
else that nude picture if that's the
case from my text messages how the hell
did I release them if you're saying that
I didn't do it off the top but they
didn't make it a big deal they kind of
just threw at it let's hit it in really
quickly and you'd have to imagine like
if they knew that you released it you'd
have been sued like crazy by now right
of course yeah the fact that you haven't
been is probably the most they did their
work restoration right right